[Musique]
alors je suis à la gare de saint vallier
je peux vous dire une chose d'avancer
très beau saint vallier mais quand les
machines remplacent les humains ça va
parfois
bon alors fait vous dire une chose quand
les machines remplacent les humains ça
va pas à quoi bon qu'il faut remplacer
ça vous mettez des gens qui restent là
toute la journée voilà
bon je vais vous dire une chose quand
les machines
remplacent les humains ça va pas quoi
donc moi je veux voilà un banquier
dehors toute la journée qui distribue
les lier
bon je vais vous dire une chose quand
les machines comme ça en place l'humain
ça va pas quoi donc il faut mettre un
concierge ici toute la journée qui lui
ouvre les portes c'est beaucoup mieux
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cham
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une info
tu as là tu as tu es là
josepha médias
[Musique]